Now this duality between a spine and
binary arithmetic is the key
to understanding how to
perform all these operations on bags
like insert, union and splitting.
Let's start with binary math.
Suppose you want to compute 23 + 1,
but do it in base 2.
Let's start by writing out 23 and
1 in binary.
So here's what you did in
computer science preschool.
See 1 + 1 is 0, carry the 1, 1 + 1 is 0,
carry the 1, 1 + 1 is 0, carry the 1.
Finally, a little variety.
1 + 0 is 1 with no carry,
and finally drop the 1.
Let's see, so did we get this right?
1, 2, 4, 8, 16, 16 + 8 is 24.
Voila.
Now, if you want to put
a single element into a bag,
you're going to do the morally
equivalent thing to binary addition.
Let's see an example.
Suppose you have a bag with 23 elements
and you want to insert a new element.
First, try to put it into the least
significant bit of the spine.
Rats, there's already a pennant there.
Okay, no big deal.
Let's create a new pennant
of twice the size.
The only gotcha now is that this
pennant is in the wrong place.
It's trying to occupy a slot along
the spine for pennants of size 1.
So, we'll need to carry
it into the next slot and
replace the current slot
with a null pointer.
Now let's repeat the process and try to
insert this new pennant into slot one.
Again, the slot's occupied so
we gotta move on.
Let's combine the 2 size 2 pennants
into a size 4 pennant, carry it, and
then 0 out the slot.
And then you basically just keep
going til the pennant that you're
carrying eventually reaches
a spot where you can insert it.
So here's a question,
what's the cost of doing this insertion?